i am chucky the killer doll
and i dig it easily the most beloved
chuckie that's how i roll yeah man
that's our role
friends till the end fan base in it yeah
chucky got a panda tv series from
sci-fi all right cool sci-fi and usa
dual networks
this show i've reacted
[Music]
eat
[Music]
how weird yeah so it's playing on
it's not just a joint effort it's it's
playing on two
channels that's my guess yeah that's
what i get how
strange for a new show am i missing
a situation where that's happened before
it's like i've heard of like reruns of
shows obviously playing on multiple
networks but i've never heard of a
brand new show playing on two separate
channels
my best guess is maybe they have the
same parent company and
maybe that parent company wants to just
expand their reach and assumes that
maybe sci-fi is not quite enough to do
it
because they probably would have to sink
at least a certain amount of money into
a show like this that has
its legacy and that also has i mean not
the jennifer tilly and brad dura for the
most expensive actors but they are tied
to this franchise they are classic
elements of it you've got don mancini
back like it's kind of a deal
you know it's a bit of a big deal yeah
man don mancini the creator for you guys
who don't know
john you got to inform people the
creator do your name drop donald
everyone has
all right cherokee franchise is
fascinating because it's always kind of
goofy and campy but then it becomes
exceptionally goofy and campy and the
quality went low and then it's like
straight to video movies
was really well received yeah better
received than the remake
right brought it back around to and i
mean the remake does horror but that you
know newest
uh cult of chucky movie yeah brought it
back to a more horror vibe
and people were surprised by like wow
the straight to dvd one is actually
pretty freaky this one's pretty good
yeah yeah to have its continuation being
a tv platform i think it's cool
i mean the thing with usa and sci-fi
though is
you can't go as hard are at you can go
violent there's still a bit of a
censorship when it comes to them
you know it's like basic cable you can
go like walking dead
r rating chucky's like very vulgar
there's a lot of f words there's a lot
of language there's
sex yeah like you can't you got to hold
back a little bit still
yeah and and that's that's something
that i am kind of
interested by because also i mean the
further we push
into streaming oriented entertainment
stuff that's not bound by a tv but more
by subscription i wonder if they can
expand upon that content because that is
probably the main concern i would have
is just you don't want them to
have to pull punches say what you will
about the later chucky movies but they
do have this
crazy garish sensibility that is very
unique to
what it is is very you know informed by
mancini's point of view and chucky has
stood in for a lot of things and there's
even like lgbtq themes in the chucky
movies
so like god you and your woke things
just get getting in the way
right damn good comments that's right
how could
i make it so that a gay man created this
to begin with oh god
oh god bringing up his sexuality
oh goodness but yeah i i don't know i i
hope that they don't have to pull
punches because
i feel like tv is a great place because
you can have
kind of all of your elements somewhere
you can have your horror you can have
your fun stuff and you can have your
more uh not that chuggy's ever been the
most relevant like
allegorical slasher movie character but
you know there's still themes they use
him for that they've expressed interest
in using him for over generations and
stuff so
i guess the main thing that excites me
about this is seeing what they want
chucky to be doing and saying now yeah i
think it's cool that it's actually
getting done
because this is one of those projects
that you hear about and you're like
i'm not sure if it's ever gonna actually
get made well and they already tried to
bring tremors back with kevin bacon shot
a pilot and didn't take it
oh fascinating so i was a little worried
almost this might befall the same fate
but luckily not i mean yeah it's because
with the way the chucky remake went down
and
like we liked it but i i still i i don't
think a lot of people did
you know not my chuck yeah i did it
definitely didn't
fly by well with the fam and i think
generally speaking the fan base of
chucky would much rather prefer they
continue forward with og
chucky brad doroth in the uh voicing it
yeah and having the soul and the creator
george lucas yeah so i think this is
uh this is a good idea a little bit
skeptical on
how much they'll have to restrain
themselves on certain elements
of what chucky involves it's probably on
two networks because they have to
compete with streaming and this is the
best way you could do it we'll see
we'll see how it turns out people but
are you guys excited for this
you think it'll be good leave your
thoughts down below subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell
catch you guys soon